hi in this video we are going to talk
about oxidation of poly and mono
unsaturated fatty acids now if we talk
about fatty acids that are present in
human body there are quite a lot of
different types for example saturated
fatty acid and mono unsaturated fatty
acid and polyunsaturated fatty acid so
what are exactly these classifications
so these classifications are based on
whether they have unsaturation in their
moiety or not for example simply the
presence of double bonds in case of
emitting acid which is an example of
saturated fatty acid you have no double
bond in this whole molecule but in case
of MOFA or mono unsaturated fatty acid
whose great example is oleic acid has a
particular one double bond at ninth
position in case of PUFA which is
polyunsaturated fatty acid which has
more than one double bond present in
ninth and two of location is known as
polyunsaturated fatty acids such as
linolenic acid or linoleic acid etc so
we are going to talk about how the
oxidation of all these different type of
fatty acid takes place now when we try
to understand this process we should ask
two questions
first of all does the catabolism of
saturated fatty acid and unsaturated
fatty acids takes place in the similar
fashion similar place and the enzymes
which are used are similar or not second
we should also ask is there any distinct
machinery for oxidation of different
subtypes of fatty acids or there is a
universal machinery which takes care
about all of these things and the answer
is overall machinery for fatty acid
oxidation is pretty much conserved
throughout species and throughout the
animal kingdom but the way you oxidize
polyunsaturated and monounsaturated
fatty acid
is big different so there are some
special enzymes which play a crucial
role in this process and we have to
learn about those enzymes to understand
this process better so just to remind
you about the beta oxidation process of
very acid and in this first example we
are going to take an example of
saturated one before looking unsaturated
fatty acid so in this case look at it so
this is a permit oil co a which is
derived from pamita acid a 16 carbon one
right
permit will Co a is converted to trans
two in oil co a look at that beta carbon
number of hydrogen has been reduced and
the enzyme that triggers this reaction
is known as ISIL Kuwait dehydrogenase as
the name suggests it performs the
hydrogenation or oxidation in this
process fadh2 is produced further trans
to in oil co a is converted to bit
hydroxy acid quayle look at the beta
carbon there is a hydroxy group now that
means it is further oxidized and the
enzyme is in oil co a hydratase further
it gets converted to beta key to assign
Kawai now from alcohol group it becomes
a ketone and the enzyme is beta hydroxy
acid hydrogenase ultimately with the
help of thiolase
one molecule of acetyl co is released
and it forms a si away so from Parma to
ELQ away after one cycle of beta
oxidation Mideast oil co a which is a 14
carbon compound would be generated and
this cycle would go on and on and each
step one molecules of acetyl co a would
go out so just to just to give you a
quick idea sixteen carbon per material
quayle would ultimately general generate
eight molecules of acetyl co a that
acetyl co a can be used in different
biochemical processes such as Krebs
cycle or maybe that as it
can be used for kitten body generation
but all these things are important to
understand when we are understanding the
beta-oxidation pathway so it's a four
step enzymatic process and henceforth we
are going to simplify that just by
saying beta-oxidation so let's look at
what are the steps which are different
in case of a poly or monounsaturated
fatty acid just to keep things simple
let's begin with the mono unsaturated
fatty acid first right so let's talk
about the oxidation of monounsaturated
fat and to give you a quick idea that
monounsaturated and polyunsaturated
fatty acids are present in avocado
almond Holly you've other dry fruits
olive oil
dark chocolate etc so these are the
great source of monounsaturated fatty
acids now all it is an abundant 18
carbon mono unsaturated fatty acid which
has unsaturation that means a double
bond between carbon 9 and carbon 10
depicted here in red now let's look at
the oxidation process of all eight to
understand so first of all we need to
get inside the mitochondria the process
is very similar it would become aligned
Kawai with the help of transferase
enzyme right and it would be it would be
taken inside the mitochondria by
carnitine shuttle system if you don't
know about carnitine shuttle system do
watch my biochemistry playlist and learn
about current in shuttle system which is
a crucial subtle system for fatty acids
now the olla alkaway would undergo three
rounds of beta oxidation I mean each
four step processes are depicted by one
arrow in this particular example and
after three rounds of beta oxidation
process what would be generated is known
as sis Delta 3 dodeca know alkaway
and 3 molecules of acetyl co a would be
released right because each cycle of
beta oxidation generates one molecule of
acetyl co a 3 molecules of acetyl co is
now released
from there sis three-door Technol Quay
is acted upon by a specific enzyme which
is known as Delta 3 Delta to annoy away
isomer reigns
so overall isomerase and reductase
enzymes are key players for oxidation of
unsaturated fatty acids this isomerize
enzyme would change the double bond
location in in-between Dale in between
second and third carbon you can look at
this structure right now and it would
form a trance 3 door decking oil Co a
previously it was a sis isomer now it
would be a trans isomer and the arrow
depicts that it's a trance after that
there would be five rounds of beta
oxidation again now five rounds of beta
oxidation would generate ultimately six
molecules of fatty acid right six
molecules of acetyl COAS sorry six
molecules of acetyl co a and all of
these acetyl co a would ultimately be
utilized in energy production or maybe
in ketone body synthesis so now we
looked at how mu feh or monounsaturated
fatty acid oxidation takes place so
let's look at PUFA but before that I
wanted to talk about the key aspect that
we need to remember when we are talking
about mono unsaturated fatty acid
oxidation here the double bond location
that the sis isomer that the sis format
or sis three-door D Colonel quake can
not be recognized by Annoying KO a
hydratase so far the reaction cannot
take place
that is why and then inthere the
summarize enzyme comes into the picture
it forms a trans isomer which can be
further detected by you know Alcoa
hydratase and as a result further
reaction can takes place now we talked
about oxidation of polyunsaturated fatty
acid
so all the oily fish such as salmon tuna
eggs chia seeds flax seeds almond
walnuts all of these things are very
good source of polyunsaturated fatty
acid one popular polyunsaturated fatty
acid is linoleic away on Lynn Lynn
allele at linoleic acid linoleic acid
would form Lynn Lake away and it has
double bond in two distinct position in
9th and 12th position so let's look at
what happens so here also there are
several enzyme several isomers and
reductive enzymes which are unique for
and which are unique and crucial for
oxidation so first of all few rounds of
fatty acid oxidation would take place
three rounds and after that three acetyl
co molecules would be ejected after that
there would be conversion of the double
bond using two three in oil co a isomer
raise it would convert sis form to the
transform then two for Dino a reductase
followed by in oil co isomerase together
would shift the double bond location and
change the type of isomer mostly they
would convert it into a trans isomer
which are recognized by the enzymes
present in our body once this conversion
is done it would be ultimately running
the same conventional beta oxidation
process which would ultimately generate
several molecules of acetyl co a and
these acetyl co a could be channeled
into cyclic acid cycle or maybe in
ketone body biosynthesis want to know
more about each one by body biosynthesis
and how ketone bodies are utilized so
look at my biochemistry playlist I have
elaborated videos about ketone body
metabolism and how it is important now I
wanted to tell you
that the triglycerides which is a
storable form of fat which is stored
inside our adipose tissue might not have
saturated fatty acid as such it might
also have PUFA and mu far as their
component so all of these adipose tissue
and adipose tissue triglycerides could
have far more fur and also saturated
fatty acid and there is a mixture of all
of these things now whenever there is a
starvation situation these fatty acids
are freed up so the glycerol is broken
so the glycerol and the fatty acids are
broken down from triglyceride glycerol
is channelled for new glucose Genesis
purpose but these fatty acid is
transported to the liver such that
oxidation of the fatty acid can takes
place and now we learn and appreciate
the difference between saturated and
unsaturated fatty acid oxidation process
so we covered quite a lot of aspects of
fatty acid oxidation in this video if
you like this video give it a big thumbs
up don't forget to like share and
subscribe and thank you for watching
thank you